alors excusez moi pour la voix de canard
mais je suis tout simplement
récemment je me suis mis un instrument
de musique
d'ailleurs j'ai probablement pris celui
qui est le moins utilisé au monde la
guitare alors vidé mes vieux comme je
dirais environ 95% des gens entre 14 et
l'entente à savoir plaire aux filles
[Musique]
c'est vraiment trop craquant
ouais je sais or from a bridge est non
mais c'est pas possible c'est un mec est
ridicule
comment il fait [ __ ] je sais il fait
de la guitare parce que moi tu vois je
suis pas comme ce mec avec les filles je
suis intimidée
j'ai peur je suis timide je bug salut tu
t'es ce que te passionne je te plains
embrasse moi ma mère ça veut dire quoi
ça je sais trop longtemps avec les
filles et c'est là que j'ai eu l'idée de
mettre un petit bémol sa première
guitare qu'on te refile est toujours en
état dégueulasse
l'autocollant boury le pet sur le côté
et lancre qui a bavé dessus
bah quoi j'ai quand même pas me faire
croire je suis ce mec à m'asseoir sur ma
guitare face à un porte-voix à white ra
non c'est toujours une première guitare
que ton père ou ton frère rebeller qui
datent de 769 avant jésus-christ bref
passons c'est beau d'avoir une vie terne
et encore faut-il savoir en jouer et
c'est là que vient l'étape la plus
difficile du monde
l'apprentissage alors il ya trois
techniques pour apprendre à faire dans
les guitares vaut prendre des cours
payants qui te coûteront de l'argent
c'est pas bon c'est pas pour nous chez
désolé la première consiste à demander
un pote de ta propre la guitare donc
l'ubs argentier s'il va te faire
technique plutôt longue et rageante pour
ton copain tu vois tu étais toi comme ça
puisque facile après tu grattes
e
comme ça trois mois plus tard le premier
c'est mon la fema non pas ce deuxième
combat non tu étais pas comme ça est
derrière tout prend pas de haut ok je
sais faire deux accords soul à je te
fais fingers de cul
la deuxième technique par une invention
super de notre siècle
internet est là mon cher ami si tu avais
l'habitude de te curé nez avec ce doigt
tu peux tout de suite oublier tu va très
vite comprendre pourquoi qu'est commence
à me saouler [ __ ] on accule changement
en vrai c'est dans les vidéos ça aussi
[Musique]
en passant de l'étape de l'apprentissage
verdi monté par quelques trucs plutôt
dégueulasse notamment sa chinois petite
pause parfait alors quand enfin au bout
de quelques mois tu vas savoir jouer un
morceau à peu près potable attention
j'ai dit un morceau potable pas ta façon
de jouer qui est potable passes contre
nous quand tu te bats la guitare tu
t'attendes toujours un jouet un truc de
gens là où quelques jours
y a un peu fait au bout de quelques mois
tu joues comme ça
mais dans la tête temps plutôt un truc
comme ça
alors 90% des butoirs liquidation
tellement puissante du partouche qui
consiste en fait à jouer à peu près
partout le seul morceau que tu sais
jouer
j'espère lui
ensuite quand bien même tu sais jouer
parfaitement un morceau et je fais pas
que sa jeune homme non le champ chose
sur laquelle la vie sans balcon que tu
saches de la guitare total mais moi je
ne sais pas vraiment faire deux trucs en
même temps je dois avouer que c'est
particulier quand même alors soit je
joue de la guitare
mais c'est pas mal mais tu chantes pas
en fait ben non parce que je suis en
train d'apprendre du coup j'arrive pas à
faire les dents même temps bon voilà
maintenant mai à lomé en 2013 tu sembles
pas quoi non mais tu t'es vu de tes
cheveux rhône grosse panne va soit je
sais j'ai c'est de chanter et va devoir
très joli et j'étais parce que tu es
tellement belle excuse mais je comprends
pas trop ce que tu me dis en fait
bah c'est que je vois tout juste de
commencer la guitare alors j'ai encore
un peu de mal quoi et l'artisanat
remercie moi j'ai trouvé la technique du
siècle notamment utilisé par toutes les
plus grandes stars de la planète le
playback une vie à gérer allez hop c'est
parti lance la musique
voilà qui ne va pas du dos et non non
c'est moi qui joue sam je te promets non
non je suis ça me regarde y'a pas y'a
pas de il n'ya pas n'y a pas de musique
là quand tu joues pas tu vois c'est moi
qui joue c'est quand je fais la musique
parce que c'est l'appât de away
ah ben je vais pas de soucis bien on
fait l'amour devient non jamais
je te remercie d'avoir regardé cette
vidéo tu peux cliquer sur la vidéo de
gauche prg ont écouté notre chanson qui
porte sur les grecs ou les kebabs avec
mon pote quentin ou alors cliquer sur la
vidéo de droit tous et sur dead space en
mode frayeur un temps maman et surtout
n'oublie pas ta bonne et en cliquant sur
le gros bouton rouge au dessus des deux
vidéos
pis
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]